all right let's see if this works any
better than the last one hello again
it's this one working for folks I hope
from Reno's back excellent my throat is
really dry this time ah yes it's working
good so far lovely ok this seems to be
going much better this time I wish I
could get this stuff to work
consistently uh boy how about a Tom
Baker biopic as was there any like
particularly notable I mean other than
the fact that he played Doctor Who that
you'd actually built the thing around I
mean I'm asking because I don't know did
you see my question if I did I've lost
it because I had to restart the stream
so go ahead and ask it again I'm
organized and stuff it's disturbing how
not organized I am congratulations on 33
K subs yes it had been hovering and uh
and like the 32:8 range for about a
month I was starting to annoy me so
getting over the hump 233 that that was
nice that felt good uh what superhero
movie do you think it's too much hate um
there's a few I think daredevil gets
more hate than it deserves I think
Batman Forever gets more hate than it
deserves those are sort of the two off
the top of my head I and feel free to
reassess it because I don't scroll back
through if it if it goes by me do you
think Netflix should focus on originals
or coamo or require more cable shows for
streaming I think their best bet is to
do a mix like they've been
doing as best as they're able to they're
probably gonna have to lean more on on
originals than they used to because
everybody's launching their own service
so they're not gonna license their stuff
to Netflix anymore they're gonna launch
their own thing but I expect most of
those to fail and for them to ultimately
go crawling back to Netflix Hulu Amazon
or or whoever else because most of these
companies that are launching these
things don't have the library to sustain
it whereas Netflix has been has had
years to build up its its library of
original content it can now afford to
operate without the cushion of as much
licensed stuff do you have any guideline
for patreon sponsored content like
novels oh okay
so short answer no I don't have a lot of
guidelines in place for the for the
patreon sponsored refused I actually am
gonna be doing a novel if I can get the
thing if I can finish reading the thing
with everything else I'm doing hopefully
later this month I'll be doing my first
book review so that that will be
interesting but not like the only thing
that I keep an eye on is the size and
the scope of the thing being has to be
reviewed that's why the the patreon
reviews sponsorship is sort of tiered
depending on how much you want me to
cover so that's why it's usually just
you know one movie couple episodes of a
TV show things like that but no novels
are not off limits if that if that was
what you were wondering yeah I saw the
thing about lee-evans appreciate that
best place to start on Doctor Who audio
books I just said just stick to the main
range initially they've gotten box set
mad lately and honestly I find those to
be a bit of a crapshoot I don't have a I
haven't taken in enough
Big Finish to like make a specific start
would Swan but I think things like
Jubilee chimes have been night those are
good first goes to give you a taste of
what's going on what its gonna be like
favorite genre of music I don't have one
I mean I listen to I listened to some
pop I listen to classic rock I listen to
a lot of soundtracks I listen including
video game soundtracks I you know little
metal a little folk a little Celtic it's
like it's all over the all over the shop
I know Liz droite Sabrina I don't know
that's correct
Liz watched Sabrina I did not um and she
likes Sabrina although she freely
admitted a big part of why she liked
Sabrina's she had just watched Riverdale
before that and she liked Sabrina a lot
better than Riverdale so sometimes it's
a comparative did you ever play Magic
the Gathering I did
I've still got most of my cards I
actually at one point I was started I
started in catalogue you want to have to
figure out if my collections worth any
money and it's probably worth a little
cuz I started playing back when I will I
was in middle school I was in seventh
grade when I started collecting Magic
the Gathering cards and I've still got
him so I haven't played oh geez I
haven't played him probably 16 or 17
years at this point it has been a long
time what do you think the Pirates of
the Caribbean sequels I actually think
that 2 & 3 are underrated and get a lot
more hate than they deserve for was a
mess I refuse to watch fine what else
did I have down here Oh Shazam got
another full trailer which is consistent
with the previous one and looks like
they are leaning you know pretty solidly
into the whole kid element you know the
fact that he is a kid appealing to kids
having a family audience which honestly
that's a good thing speaking personally
it doesn't actually make me want to
watch the movie any
or just because and that's just not my
bag I don't really have a lot of
interest and a goofy kid friendly
superhero but I don't feel that it
shouldn't exist cuz it doesn't appeal to
me I mean that's honestly that's what
Shazam should be if you're gonna make it
Shazam movie so it does a pretty good
job of selling what it seems like the
movie is by its I mean it's one of those
things that I'm gonna watch if it's not
inconvenient for me to do so it's not
something that I'm gonna go super out of
my way to to see any movie you'd like to
see it 20 years later sequel I actually
I got that like written down as a list
to come up with I hadn't come up with
anything on it yet as to what actually
might be might be good to do that with
would you like the DC the MCU to do a
movie based on the original Secret Wars
I not really because the Secret Wars is
a very comic-book premise it's just drop
a whole bunch of heroes and villains
onto a planet and see what happens and
it's and I know like the bar for what
you can get away with in movies that OH
you can't bring that in from comics as
like it's not in the same place it was a
while ago but I do I do feel like that
that premise just doesn't carry a movie
I just don't think it does what would
you say this is someone whose favorite
Doctor Who episode is hell-bent um what
would I say to them probably not much I
more likely have a lot of questions not
a lot of statements a lot of questions
do you know the series Law & Order SVU I
know of it I didn't know why I actually
I was on like an original Law & Order
kind of kick I don't know
decade back or so little less but SVU I
think it was just kind of a kind of
cases that they dealt with I just just
too much scheming is fir for my taste
great help and answer can you do a top
ten best new who episodes in top ten
worst new who episodes
um like I did a worse new who episodes
list a lot blank back when I still had
the green screen I did that I I gone
back and refreshed
most of my old lists that I did on
Doctor Who I don't really want to
refresh that one I just it feels too
broad I felt a lot more comfortable
narrowing it down to like doing best and
worst of specifically Davey's written
episodes and for Moffat but like just
broadly about the show I just it doesn't
I don't feel comfortable doing it any
more I feel like Doctor Who is too big
and too segmented I even knew who at
this point to do something that's
sweeping and especially with the idea of
revisiting a worst list I just I don't
like feeding into a lot of the
negativity at this point and that's not
like using there were no bad episodes oh
there about episodes I just and my heart
wouldn't be in it right now
I mean maybe again at some point but I'm
just not there right now what's your
favorite LGBT movie um whatever one
doesn't actually get filed under LGBT
movies and I was gonna say the video
store but as a data reference but the
thing is the the things that people tend
to think of when they think of LGBTQ as
a genre which it's not it's a subject
it's not a song it's not as Jean Ora but
they all tend to fall under drama and
usually some form of relationship drama
which is quite possibly the genre that I
am
the least interested in and the least
likely to seek out anything within so
there are plenty of movies that I like
with lgbtq+ characters but ones that are
like emphatically about those kinds of
characters or that kind of life I rarely
watch because they are in genres I don't
care about which is why it matters to me
whether or not there is representation
in mainstream things like superhero
movies and Harry Potter and Star Wars
and whatnot because I'd like to see that
in the things that I actually want to
see
have you seen Babylon 5 no but I did
make a joke about Babylon 5 way back
when this was originally a series of
scripted shorts i ended an episode on a
Babylon 5 chili
excuse me on Iran a joke making fun of
Babylon 5
so haven't seen it but still felt free
to make fun of it so you're welcome for
that have you seen the movie Looney
Tunes back in action I have it's not bad
the main problem is the villain doesn't
work but there's uh there's a firm I'm
out about the of that film that actually
works pretty well I agree with you about
the lgbtq+ sub-genre I wish characters
were just who they were in movies and
with less offensive annoying stereotype
yeah the stereotyping is a panda but I
mean it's to a certain extent as part of
them it's part of the normalization
process you know that just getting more
lgbtq+ characters visibly means
initially they're probably gonna be
stereotyped and we kind of have to push
through that and then start working more
nuanced ones it doesn't mean that we
have to like be okay with the
stereotyped but I just sort of do see it
as part of the it's part of the was part
of the pop culture acceptance it's a
phase of it
ah buying the Fanueil I have to go peace
out and peace out to you sponge brain
and yes you did speller right thank you
very much
best multi doctor story ah inclined to
say the three doctors I don't think the
multi doctors jurors are especially
strong though for the most part of them
being honest five doctors was decent the
five doctors wasn't bad but what they
did with four was really contrived and I
don't love the guy who they had playing
the first doctor because Hartnell had
passed away by then so I'm not a huge
fan of of the five doctors I know your
birthday soon when's your actual
birthday my actual birthday is March
21st which would make my zodiac anybody
king a king and tell me without looking
it up there's that there's the question
let's say two doctors was confusing
about enjoying the sunset the top of the
two doctors hurt man I'm sorry
Pisces no no sir
close though but no same day as my pugs
birthday haha Ares there it is yeah mom
you weren't actually that wrong with the
Pisces guests cuz March 21st is the very
first day of the Aries star sign and
actually I'm barely in Aries because I
was born at midnight three minutes four
minutes earlier and I would have been a
Pisces so it's hard to get much more on
the cusp than I am I don't like a lot of
stock in astrology but I find it fun all
the same Aquarius
yeah now people just thrown out their
star signs that's fun how far are you
into classic who well I can't really
judge that because I'm not going through
it chronologically I'm jumping around
all over the place
should like figure out like what
percentage of classic who I've watched
at this point cuz I actually don't know
I should do that but because I'm not
doing it chronologically I don't have an
easy marker for me to say
Gemini apparently there's a video that
that's talking about something else
favorite sonic that you own well
favorite one that I own which is diff
which would be different for my fav
you're probably 12 just be because I
like that it has more than one color you
know it's actually I got to replace the
battery in it oh yeah that battery's
going actually there's several of these
I need to replace the batter in I should
do that clean unfortunately a lot of
these users really annoying battery
sizes they use like the little round
ones that are like in hearing aids on
the cusp of cancer and Leo how we doing
for time how about 15 minutes left to go
cool can do that which Doctor Who older
new episode is the best place to start
when showing a new watcher I mean I
stand by my feeling that if you want to
try and show some get somebody hooked in
on the concept of Doctor Who who knows
literally nothing about it you just want
to show an episode to hook their
interest I say show them blink cuz blink
explains itself as it goes along
requires no preamble it's totally
self-contained and I think sells the
show very well is it you know an example
of what the show normally is well no but
it does a lot of work in terms of
pitching it to be blick was what I
showed Liz to see if she was interested
in seeing more now if you're asking for
an episode to show and then they go from
there that's a little trickier I for my
view eleventh hour is probably the way
to go although the pilot honestly
wouldn't be a terrible place to start
and then work your way forward from
either
um that's my feelings though you start
getting into saying you know Oh skip
these errors of dark true and that's not
actually what I'm saying I was I'm
saying like use that as a starting point
I gave you to say do eleventh-hour
have them watch live in that were
watched all of series five and then at
that point decide whether to go back and
start earlier or to keep going and then
go back but to ideally then eventually
take it all in see Devils or Silurians I
actually like the Sea Devils a little
better and I'm waiting for them to come
back on the show um I had one more news
item down here so does anybody remember
that New Mutants was a movie that was
supposed to come out a year ago and just
keeps getting pushed back well that may
end up just getting dropped on Disney
Plus not confirmed but that's the latest
word on that and at this point I'm just
kind of throwing my hands up and going
I'm just never gonna get to see this
movie and I I'm Way more curious in
getting a detailed behind-the-scenes
look at what went down with the making
and marketing of this thing that I am
and actually seen the movie at this
point but it is which water companion
would you have liked to see with a
different doctor me I would love to have
seen Graham with Capaldi that's an
interesting question I think that parent
that pairing might be just a little too
much older gentleman for me a character
dynamic wise that would be interesting
so if I were to switch around honestly I
would put Martha with Capaldi because I
feel like he'd appreciate her a heck of
a lot more than Tennant it that's that's
the first one off the top of my head
sometimes questions just get missed no
matter how many times they're asked yes
that's true also you know sometimes
there are questions that I see and I i
willfully ignore or it's too similar to
a question that could asked earlier in
the in the live stream that happens
sometimes too and I skip it for that so
you know what can I say
favorite episode of each new doctor mg
child and the doctor dances silence in
the library forest to the Dead Vincent
and the doctor Heaven Sent and it takes
you away there you go I was able to do
that one off the top of your head what's
some of the nicest most heartwarming
comments you've had in general actually
most of the the real heartwarming stuff
has haven't shown up in the comments
it's I've had people actually send me
emails sometimes very very detailed ones
or direct messages you know sharing
something with me about how you know
something that I did or said you know
help them through something or help them
come to a better understanding or or
whatever it was I don't want to give out
specifics because a lot of those like I
said since they were directly emailed
indirect messages a lot of that was for
privacy reasons they went some of these
went into very personal details I bet
it's not my place to share but there
have been there's been some really
touching stuff you keep missing black
clovers 1995 okay yes okay
black black Cubs are black cover 95 you
did say you were gonna add something
again I said go ahead and ask it again
and then Act I do that one I literally
keep missing whatever that is I keep
looking back for it and not seeing it go
ahead and ask it again I will I will
answer it do you think series 9 would be
boosted up if that's when bill joy not
really
I mean I actually think series 9 is
pretty decent
up until a hell-bent have you watched
sheer on the princesses of power yet
yeah yeah did a review of the first
season I'll probably review the second
season are you a member of any
little-known fandoms I don't know
because I I mean lucky freelance is
pretty niche so where that guy comes
from that might be be the most so our
Harry Potter fans the nerdiest of all
fandoms I would think that they would be
right up there with Star Trek fans in
terms of like getting into real extreme
specifics about but the thing they're a
fan of dual Blake 7 Blake 7 review um
probably not unless somebody
Commission's me to do it man
I just won't have time pinion on The
Princess Bride it's a classic and it's a
classic for a good reason and also
probably one of the best examples of how
to properly adapt a novel to to a movie
thoughts on Dumbledore's gay rep he's
not until it's confirmed in in Canon
somewhere he's not so no I don't have an
opinion let me back up here see
sorry I'm trying to back up and find
something cuz there's a somebody thought
I was deliberately ignoring their
question and now I'm trying to find
where was asked in the first place
oh oh okay
it was it was a it was the pronouns
question okay
so I apologize for missing that I was
not deliberately ignoring it I did
legitimately just not see it asked
pronouns are whatever you want to use
the the real answer is my pronouns are
situational because gender fluid means
my own personal sense of gender it does
that it doesn't stay put and I don't
expect anyone to keep up with my own
shifting sense of self therefore I don't
expect other people to shift their use
of he or she and especially considering
that you might be talking about me when
I'm not even present for you to cue off
me to know where I'm at and in the given
point I just tell people to whatever
makes the most sense to you whatever
comes in your head when you think of me
whether it's he or she or they just go
with that I'm not picky and I will not
be offended with whatever it is don't
call me it that's that's pretty much the
only thing that I ask other than that
whatever whatever works for you whatever
makes sense in your own head and again
I'm sorry I missed it I was not
deliberately ignoring that I like every
time that I would glance back it was
nowhere in the block of text that I was
looking at and then I glanced up and
that's probably when it got asked again
so I am sorry about that phase four
phase four predictions
well I predict I'm sorry I just picked
on a typo that's petty I'm sorry about
that um I don't really have any because
I don't I don't know enough about what
the state of the MCU is gonna be none of
us do
so what I would say
is I I expect they will probably try and
find a way to sneak Lee introduce Kamala
Khan and then probably used her down the
line now that they're introducing
Captain Marvel other than that's like
about the only specific prediction I'm
prepared to make have him have you used
that pronoun pin yet I still really want
yes I did um couple of weeks ago not
there so not this past Friday but the
Friday before went out with Liz that I
wore it that yeah hi I had a lot of fun
with that are you more excited for MCU
Fantastic Four MCU x-men Fantastic Four
because we haven't had a good Fantastic
Four movie yet so that I'm a little bit
more more interested in its stay I use a
wheelchair and I've gotten called it
before it's offensive for anyone well
yeah yeah a human being is better than
that excited for Captain Marvel um yeah
not like the most pumped but yeah I I
expect it to be fun I expect it to be
enjoyable and probably not gonna get
around to it until Sunday because I have
a packed weekend as I often do do you
ever want to do a panel at Comic Con I'd
love to be on a panel the thing is I
don't this is really irritating because
like every now and then people would be
like hey you know you should be on you
should be on a panel you should give a
talk like seriously I'd love to do that
stuff I don't know how you get booked to
do it but I like yeah I seriously don't
I don't know if you if it a lot of them
seem to be a don't ask
if we want you will ask you type
scenario and I'm not big enough to be on
the radars most of these things and like
the few that I got the vibe that you
could just sort of put out hey I'm
available like don't seem to care so
like I just don't I just don't know and
the thing is most youtubers who are of a
size where this is their living like
they're in the hundred thousand
subscriber range or whatnot most of them
have gotten a PR person who books this
stuff for them or an agent or something
I don't have that so and doing it myself
that's the end of this entire thing that
I am view worst at and I'm I don't
particularly enjoy it not say I wouldn't
enjoy doing a pet I don't enjoy figuring
out how to make that stuff happen I hate
that logistics networking I hate it and
I suck at it which is is the reason it's
one of the reasons that I know it's why
some youtubers have basically done more
with less
there are youtubers with a smaller
subscriber count and general footprint
that I have that have managed to make
more out of it you had it lead to other
bigger things cuz they know how to
network and I don't so there you go we
should do a who tuber panel at a local
comic-con I would be absolutely down for
that the problem is most of the local
cons going on are on weekends that I
can't do so like I because I've been
trying to figure what I'm gonna do for
cons this year
Vermont comic-con looks like it's just
flat-out not happening this year which
bums me out
so I'm looking right now the top the top
two candidates for cons that I'm
probably gonna go to or like could go to
I can't do both I can't afford to do
both would be either terrific on or
heroes con terrific on in Connecticut in
jus or maybe that one's in August one of
them is in June one of them is in August
I mean the and heroes con is it
North Carolina and those ones because
they those ones actually have to be on
weekends that I could make this work
because like I looked at I think I
looked at Granite Khan in New Hampshire
because that's a very drivable distance
for me that's on a weekend I can't go I
actually have a bunch of friends who are
going to Boston Fan Expo Comic Con this
year and it's on a weekend I can't make
it so like it's this the schedule is
just not kind to me this year when it
comes to the cons gay lexicon last I
know it was in math and math that
spelling makes me very curious as to
whether that's a typo or if that's
implying about the comm what I think
might be let's see yeah I think Montreal
ComicCon I think I can't remember if I
looked at the date are Montreal I might
have I can't remember now know Rose City
for you either boot no Rose City I mean
that that's also that also would be a
major hall for me to make that one edge
and cons can be tough I hope to make it
to Granite State yeah I had I had hope
that was gonna get to Granite State this
year but it's just that the timing
doesn't work out are you gonna watch
Good Omens with David Tennant oh yeah oh
yeah it's coming out on Amazon I have
Amazon I'm gonna watch it how would you
design the TARDIS I'm no designer like
it believe if you could see my roam
aside from this corner it's a disaster
like I am not organized I'm not a
designer you don't want me to design a
TARDIS like if I had a TARDIS it would I
I would be the one person who'd find a
way to fill up the entire bigger on the
inside space with just junk and it's not
like I'm a hoarder
I don't like oh I can't get rid of it
I'm nervous I just have no organization
stuffs just em
we're uh asked about LGBT pew lgbtq+
Khan gathering that's what I was
wondering if that was cuz I saw the name
of that condom and I'm like so okay
I actually that hadn't been on my radar
and now I'm gonna I'm gonna look that up
just out of curiosity if nothing else
and we're actually starting to run a
little bit long at this point so I think
I am going to wrap it up there so yeah
I'm sorry this one was a little bit of a
mess this time and I had to stop it
started this is one of the less
organized streams I've had recently Oh
okay so next week normally next week
stream would be a 7 p.m. eastern time
next week is also going to be a 9 p.m.
it's because I've got a work-related
thing that is gonna keep me late and
seven just isn't gonna be viable so next
week is also going to end up being 9
p.m. and then so was the week after that
and then it'll get back onto the onto
the back and forth like it's supposed to
be because as long as my day job is
what's paying my bills sometimes that
has to take priority as much as I love
you folks don't tell my boss okay so
that yeah
I'll wrap it up there so thanks
everybody for tuning in putting up with
technical issues and everything else I
hope you all have a great week if you go
see Captain Marvel hope you enjoy it and
yeah see you know seeing it see you next
week